trying to say something okay Heather
Mills sitting just to my left here at
this news desk would be me is the owner
and consumer of possibly the best
Smelling Coffee I have ever oh uh had
the pleasure of it smell good doesn't it
what is that oh yeah something yummy
it's a Keurig pod and my you know
reusable Starbucks mud see I'm so green
that is that is environmentally friendly
that has brightened my morning hopefully
you're brightening your morning
smell-o-vision four o'clock let's talk
about the weather forecast Jerry good
morning to you good Tuesday you guys
well it's your reusable cup Heather it
could have many many flavors left over
in it
but it's got you know it's just got
Essence it has experience lots of good
cups of coffee well good Tuesday
everybody you might be uh getting ready
to make that pot of coffee this morning
we're still pretty warm out there after
hitting 104 yesterday afternoon as
forecasted uh 87 degrees 32 percent
humidity and 54 is the dew point
humidity down slightly it's going right
back up and it looks like we're going to
be stuck with that Monsoon humidity
today 605 a.m is the sunrise we had a
little flare-up of thunderstorms in the
higher elevations where we did say that
we'd have a chance of storms yesterday
they fizzled out pretty quickly we'll be
back to about 90 degrees mid-morning
upper 90s by noon a very hot day for the
Las Vegas Valley at 106 with triple
digits right through dinner time and
still a slight chance of afternoon
storms for the mountains today so be
careful if you're heading up to the
higher elevations 402 doing good Tuesday
morning to Nate tannenbong I have a
reusable coffee cup you sure do I've
seen you reuse it over and over again
I've been using this coffee cup at work
for 40
years no no no way I started using this
coffee cup in 1982. man on the graveyard
shift at cozy 101. wow
downtown Aurora Colorado
all right let's get to the freeway